My Name Is mu hanifa and I'm part of the
ca McMillan multiscale human program I
think CA is unique in being able to
bring a diverse range of individuals to
solve one problem where we go next in
mapping the human body uh and sometimes
these the Assembly of expertise is not
so obvious um and it includes people
from industry from engineering from
physics from astronomy there are just
many different um skill sets that are
really required to to make this advance
and that is exactly what CA allows us to
achieve um is it possible to map the
human body absolutely um if we bring all
of these you know amazing you know minds
and and and expertise and and
camaraderie and working as a team yes
why
[Music]
not